how did the film come about so after I
got in a little bit of trouble for the
poker game that I was running I kept
looking at this constantly accruing debt
sheet of legal bills my mom put her
house up to bail me out of jail and you
know I'm gonna be a convicted felon
where what am I gonna do am I gonna get
a job who's gonna hire me and you know
I'm known as the poker princess so I
said well there's a story here and so I
I wrote the book and then I went to
Hollywood and I asked anyone who would
listen to me if I could meet Aaron
Sorkin most people laughed at me and I
met at an entertainment attorney Ken
Hertz he sent him the book and then
afforded me an email from Aaron said I
look forward to meeting Molly boom Wow
yeah it was cool it was also a cool
moment when Molly found out that Jessica
Chastain would player in the film and
now Jessica's performance is being
recognized during awards season
including a Golden Globe nomination and
what was your relationship life to her
we spent a little time together she
didn't have much time for prep and she
didn't have much time for for research
so yeah it was just a couple times and
then a couple of phone calls and I was
blown away by her performance and how
right on it was and how deep and
understood I felt by her performance
because it's my name my friends and
family that saw it we're just in shock
they're like she sounds like you should
gets you it's like watching you um and I
think she put her own spin on things too
which made it even cooler people
obviously love the movie what was like
being at the Globe
it was exciting you know I mean I didn't
know how this thing was gonna end up
this was a hard movie to get made there
was a lot of people that didn't want to
make this movie a lot of powerful people
why are you hanging that it I think they
were worried about how they were gonna
be portrayed in the film Michael Cera
portrays player acts widely thought to
be a combination of celebrities that
attended Molly's poker games including
Ben Affleck Leonardo DiCaprio and Tobey
Maguire's let's play you write about a
story where Tobey Maguire asks you to
mark like a seal for $1,000 poker chip
mm-hmm sounds super misogynistic
degrading I mean is that is that an
accurate portrayal that's an accurate
portrayal yeah and that was an important
story to tell
for me to tell at the time and this was
you know before we were really sort of
openly having these conversations but
not because it was him because I didn't
do it and I lost the game that's part of
the reason why I lost the game but I
started another game you know and it was
bigger and it was more successful I
think it's just really important to
remember that you don't have to do
everything everyone tells you to do you
know you don't have to come at it out of
fear if it's your dignity on the line
lose your dignity there are people that
have already been outed in the public
medium I can mention those names I can
give color on this world
it's an exciting story on its own it
doesn't require this that the celebrity
take down and blackmail never cross your
mind know
I've committed enough federal crime
scene